لسرقه العيديه طفلين قتلوا صاحبهم في
العيد فما القصه
احداث الواقعه ترجع لبلاغ اهالي احدى
القرى بمحافظه البحيره تالت ايام العيد
بالعثور على جثه الطفل مصطفى البالغ من
العمر 11 سنه تلميذ في الصف الثالث
الابتدائي داخل منزل مهجور
وتوصلت جهود فريق البحث الجنائي ان ورم
نقطه لطفل صحابه اللي من نفسه عمره تقريبا
كانوا بيلعبوا مع بعض وفجاه اتفقوا يخنقوه
ويسرقوا عيديته المقدره بمبلغ 100 جنيه
وهربوا
وبعد ضبط المتهمين افادت اقوالهم انهم بعد
ما تركوا المجني عليه اشتروا مكرونه سريعه
التحضير وشيبسي بالمبلغ اللي سرقوه
واعترفه كمان بانهم بحثوا عن المجني عليه
مع اهله والصحبو بعض الاطفال بغرض اللهو
داخل المنزل المهجور حتى يتمكنوا من
العثور على جثه المجني عليه
الوقعه هزت الراي العام واثارت غضب الجميع
وقررت محكمه الطفل بايتايه البارود
بمحافظه البحيره اذاعه طفلين باحدى دور
الرعايه الاجتماعيه
[موسيقى]